[Music]
you're likely to spot them only in the
most remote of places where the wind
blows fiercest giant wind turbines their
increasingly supplying more and more of
our clean energy and when they break
down they need to be fixed fast it's a
job only a few people are equipped to
handle those who are afraid of heights
need not apply
you're basically doing construction work
on ropes
most people think god you're insane
but that's totally dangerous but
actually it's statistically safer than
driving to work when you're driving past
wind turbines on the highway you may
never know that there's somebody up
there dangling but next time should look
up there because you might see me
[Music]
Jessica Kilroy is a rock climber but she
makes her living as a wind turbine
technician repairing damaged turbine
blades on towers that are as tall as 350
feet it's easy to do this job safely you
just have to do it carefully I'm a rock
climber and it's obviously when you're
rock climbing all the time you're not
making any money you end up leaving your
van and wondering how you're gonna pay
the bills
rock climbing and blade repair require
the same skills being able to have no
fear of heights be comfortable in ropes
as well as being able to figure out how
to get yourself out of a weird situation
here in Plymouth Massachusetts the
average wind speed is 20 miles per hour
but these turbines can easily operate it
wins twice that strength since wind
farms are built in remote areas the
turbine towers themselves are often the
tallest structures for miles this can
make them perfect lightning rods towers
have lightning protection systems the
ground electricity but sometimes
lightning exits out of the blade
damaging its fiberglass exterior blades
can also crack due to weather erosion
from dust rain snow and ice exposing its
wooden interior to corrosive moisture if
left unchecked the blades will weaken
and eventually break off the tower
that's the main problem and we don't
want blades just breaking off that's
usually why we repair them as soon as
possible usually you see like a small
dark spot and that's where Lightning has
struck and then you can grind into it
and look further and see how deep it
goes we repair the fiberglass using
Sanders and grinders and crowbars or
whatever you need to get the job done
it's really similar to surfboard repair
except there's 350 feet of nothing
that's beneath me you're on the blade
and you straddle it and the wind is
bucking you around and you're on a bowl
feel like I'm in the rodeo
I think it's easy for people to look at
me and think blonde chick climber life
must come easy for her but I've had to
fight for this life I was born with my
bones not aligned correctly I had to
wear straight leg braces up until high
school the doctor said I could not do so
many things they said you can't do this
you can't do that and like my dad is a
climber back in the 80s in the 90s my
dad and his friends were out climbing
big walls and putting up first ascents
in the Tetons and I was just like dude
you guys are the coolest ever and I want
to be you guys I had so many years as a
kid I'm just looking at climbing
magazines and watching my friends
running around outside jump roping
playing basketball doing all the things
that I wanted to do the parts hard sorry
I decided I'm not going to let people's
limits be my limits and I decided to go
so much further past what I even thought
my own limits were
[Music]
the first thing I usually do is harness
that there's a ladder in the inside it's
350 feet tall and you just climb every
run of that ladder all the way up to the
top the view from the top is expansive
and just awesome through the tallest
thing around you can get butterflies in
your stomach a little bit there is
outside risk because job
there's adverse weather conditions as
well as forest fires this summer I was
on a wind turbine where a wildfire just
came rolling through we failed
really quick and when we were out you
know driving away I have a picture out
the window and the wind turbine was just
like swept up in the fire
I feel blessed to be able to be in some
of the most beautiful places in the
world except I get to help the
environment I get to feel like I'm
actually contributing to the green
energy movement there are over 4,400
wind turbine technicians in the United
States with jobs expected to double in
the next 10 years
next time you're passing a wind turbine
look close look real close you might see
a little speck up there and that little
speck might be me living my dream